[Music]
welcome and we are live I'm a podcast
lords of gaming dotnet and who's the
special gentleman that we have in the
realm a man of rank how you doing I'm
Jake Bell do you know and I'm very happy
to be here I'm glad you guys were able
to take the time we really appreciate
that you take the time to talk to us
definitely one of the bigger YouTube
personalities in the game
Loren aldo also was making me very aware
of your content as well you know me so
let's get right into as far as your
youtube journey you getting started you
got I mean let's let's trot that whole
progress and tell people to the world
who don't know you about your channel we
started in like I feel like we started
how we should we started in the basement
and it was me actually I think my first
PAX East was 2012 yeah so I had been
coming and grinding and trying to make
things happen and eventually I got a gig
with game ranks which was just a website
at the time and they were like you know
everybody's going to video so we got to
get a video out there so they just threw
me a couple bucks to start making videos
I was still going to college I was still
working at a grocery store but I just
wanted to break in so I was like yeah
I'll take any gig it's paying it's just
a little bit but hey so they gave me a
blank YouTube channel and they said
alright you know like how our website
works so trying to just kind of keep the
content in line with that and we
developed a strategy and just kind of
grind it out and just went from there so
what I think the elevator pitch of game
ranks I think is top 10 channel you come
for the top tens you click on the top
tens and stuff like that the attractive
stuff but you stay for the personality
like you click on it it's like hey it's
a top 10 PlayStation games but you hear
real people you know we do we do a lot
of ad-libbing we don't do like 100%
scripts it ok yeah we wanted to like
keep it like alright cool like the
content I worked for the the website but
we actually wanted you know
we wanted to just be cool you know
because I had been trying to I had
actually started as a like a movie and
commentary youtuber during probably like
the last couple years of high school
with a friend so I had kind of started
to like learn the environment learn what
works what doesn't work and tried to
translate it to gaming it's a game so
far so good so great foundation kind of
like Brian in front of us so like what
advice would you give a lot of starting
youtubers or people getting in the game
from a content creation standpoint what
are some of the things you may have
learned during experience in your
journey I think the first thing is
coming here doing this like 100 percent
like even if you have five dollars to
your name like I would come and I would
buy a box of cereal and that's all I
would have a it was grinding yeah you
know it was like exactly ramen noodles
like every day yeah and it was so it was
that and then like eventually working up
to three so think you kind of have to
level yourself up through the events and
put yourself out there even if you're
nervous the groundwork hitting the
shoals going out this is good advice
meeting people talking to people also
just being on social media you have to I
would always say like earlier days of
Twitter I'd say if you don't have
Twitter get one because you can at least
have your ear to the ground you don't
have to be like viral and popular but
you have to have an idea of what's going
on you have to know about job postings
you have to know about what people are
doing how people are working stuff like
that and also on the YouTube side just
consistency yes learn SEO learn
algorithms and just learn what people
click on entertain people but just kind
of keep feeding the beast to always keep
uploading always keeping people
satisfied that's really that's really
the main thing so what questions you got
for what would you say it was like the
thing that ended up making you kind of
um kind of like boom I could propel
yourself forward what was the more lates
was the one thing that kind of like put
that in your mind that was a good one
ever asked me that oh you know it wasn't
fallout 4 whoa
fallout 4 was like the the viral game
for us where we did like one or two
videos on it and they kept blowing up
and we're like we got
go we gotta go we gotta keep makin
follow because these people want him out
so we came up with every idea we could
and those kind of were able to bring us
to the next level of you know like
beefing up a little bit putting a little
more money into it so you have a team
that you kind of work with on the
channel itself how many have any of
those people kind of work with you we
are we're kind of split up but I have I
have two guys with me in an office and
then we have three other people remotely
throughout the world I'm sorry no and
it's just like everybody does a little
bit of everything you know we all do
some some writing some ideas and some
editing some of there's some some
capturing stuff like that you know we're
trying to get more people like on on the
camera because you know so um so your
team you guys kind of just sit down and
just kind of just spit ball ideas like
how do you think of ideas to keep with
the going trends because you know like
when it comes to gaming and it's coming
to like streaming and coming to like
people producing content as content
creators you kind of have to evolve your
channels as the games change because not
only do people sit in one game and
seeing those genres how does it kind of
go into one to another I think what
we've tried to do is keep people keep
like listening essentially what what are
people yelling about on Twitter what are
the big things going on on Reddit like
what do people responding to the most
even we'll go as far as to look on
YouTube and say all right what new game
trailers are getting the most views like
what where is there the most interest
and then we pretty much go from there
the biggest thing that we've been
struggling with is exactly you said like
people playing games games evolving over
time we're straight-up still trying to
figure out a game plan for that because
we put out a you know a review on SIA
thieves we put out a review on Rainbow
six siege and you know they weren't that
hot at first but now they're fantastic
so we're trying to figure out how the
best ways are to revisit that get that
out to people in different ways cuz
streamers are killing it in that regard
yeah there's like an entire community of
CO thieves as entire community as each
and we kind of want to get on that
that's honestly I guess for me is like
um what specific I know sometimes it's
that balance right where it's like you
have to do it like what PD was saying in
terms of you know what the community is
looking for the type of trends that are
kind of happening versus sometimes your
own personal battle maybe you have
things that you really enjoy doing but
they may not hit so like how do you
balance that as a greater we basically
kind of go until we're stressed out and
then we kind of settle back down and say
all right let's write about Tony Hawk
like we know a lot not a lot of people
are gonna watch Tony Hawk's Pro Skater
videos but let's make one anyone that
and just yeah that's really it that's
that's it it's just every once in while
when were jammed up let's pump the
brakes the biggest thing the biggest
fight is not feeding the negativity
machine you know I always joke but I'm
like we would all be gazillionaires if
all we did was the negative you know
there's you have to you know obviously
fight for the consumer that's like a big
part of our you know what we talk about
but when you focus on it all the time
it's like you're lost you know it's like
the Jedi are lost the force is what he's
saying yeah so so then what would you
what would you say that then keeps you
like genuine kind of keeps you grounded
for that for us like that's something
that we try to we try to keep the
podcast channel genuine keshi results
grounded and and for us that's like each
other like we kind of keep each other in
check what would you say that you and
your team does keep each other kind of
like you know grounded in check yeah
that's awesome I think for us it's just
being very with the audience being in
the comments as much as comments can be
rough sometimes like we like being held
100% accountable that and also just not
getting too big for our what I say big
for our britches yeah you know we don't
have you we didn't buy a building we
don't have a massive staff anything like
that because we like everyone to be in
the same room or in the same Skype or in
the same theists chord and you know just
all being friends all being accountable
to one another and that's really what
kind of has worked for us so we don't
want to like we don't want to change
your to corporation this is awesome at
again you know just see a hearing about
you
just like getting high where you guys
have evolved from is pretty impressive
and then I got you guys are still doing
what you're doing you growing more
contents coming this is big stuff man
it's it's scary I we hit so we hit the
five million subscriber mark and I guess
the next milestone is what do we do now
like how do we focus on a goal that just
seems so massive you know so
insurmountable because we at the end of
the day we operate like a like an outlet
you know we're not pewdiepie we're not
one dude right so curious to see how far
we can actually push it yeah how did you
feel like when when you started you know
your channel kind of evolved and kind of
like boomed and you hit that what's the
first marker like a hundred thousand
subscribers and you get that award in
the mail like how did you how did yeah
we got the plaque how did you how did
you feel when I kind of came in and kind
of like make you feel like this is this
is worth it this is something that you
know I can actually do you know that's
exactly what it was and it was also for
me I started traditionally like I was
writing for blogs I want to be a game
journalist that's how I realized that I
got bored of writing and I wasn't very
good at writing but I had aspired to you
know getting to play a game early you
know getting to review that game so for
me it was like you know was I think it
was like Saints Row three and I was like
the first review copied it showed up on
my doorstep and I was like it's like
that first review code it's something
about it that I get based on your heart
working and you were getting that that
acquisition of that that software and
then being able to write about it being
able to comment on it's a good feeling
you know it's also - it's it's almost
someone in the industry kind of taking a
chance on you you know especially when
it's your first yeah it's like that
person has a connection to you through
text email you meet them at PAX and
they're willing to say all right I'm
gonna send this kid mmm a review copy
and then for a lot of people I've seen
all it takes is and to get early access
to one game and they grind it out do a
bunch of videos and put out the
information and people want and then you
know they go up from there
how did you had it when you starting
like you said and you were kind of
growing over time like how did you how
was your mental state because like for
myself well having having a smaller
channel and producing you know some
growth over time um like your mental
state like how did you keep yourself
like I'm I want to keep on this I want
to keep even when things were maybe not
probably you were getting that baby
progression that you were hoping for in
the beginning I hate to say it I know I
said like negative videos that you know
don't go to the dark side but I had a
chip on my shoulder you know I had I had
something to prove I wasn't happy with
going to college not knowing what I
wanted to do I wasn't happy with my
part-time job I wasn't happy with like
even like my parents they were they
didn't get it I wanted to show them I
want to show my friends but I had to see
you to this gaming style man I still now
she look at the check do you guys have
to explain it to people they're like oh
so you guys you guys make the games and
you're like oh no no no we don't we
don't make the games we're not that
smart so what do you what do you do and
I'm like disconnect they don't
understand but it's it's fun it's still
something I never take for granted to
even be say that was yeah
oh sorry so um so how did your headed
your how did your family feel when you
kind of like show them hey I could do
this like we're pushing we're gonna
believe how do they feel like their
their mindset change on it my my dad is
the one who is a bit more stone cold and
then when the first check showed up yeah
he was like okay let me help you and he
was able to kind of guide me from there
and that was cool my mom I still have to
explain this is again just to hear these
stories the haters it really gives guys
like us confidence you know I'm saying
because again here are some from the
grassroots from the grind
you know hitting these shows like you
were saying earlier you know doing these
events having that passion and then
sticking with it even during the low
tops this is really inspirational stuff
man so it's good to see
you know what fun of us come up from the
ranks any other questions with the Lord
of gay breaks before you wrap up I'm
good
well look you got it heard of here first
this guy's story's amazing the channel
is the main continue on with your
journey absolute pleasure to have you in
the realm of the Lords the legendary
game Rex here in the realm my man
Lord gave me a little I don't know
podcasts at it up
[Music]